- I hear that we share a secret nemesis.
- Yes, yes we do.
I am a huge fan of "The Voice,"
so, yes, I love watching
people's dreams come true.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- And so I cry every episode
but I'm always just rooting
against Blake Shelton.
- I love it.
- Because my favorite
artist is never on his team.
No disrespect to those artists,
they are all incredible,
obviously, but like he just wins so much.
- Okay, I'm not going
to say that on the show.
- No, you're right.
- I'm kidding.
I'm just kidding, no, he does win a lot.
So it is our goal, collectively,
as the other coaches
to beat him.
- Yeah, and I'm with you on that.
- Until Ariana comes then
our collective goal will be
to not lose so tremendously
so to Ariana Grande.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yep.
- One of my favorite
moments from this season
was your team singing POV,
Ariana Grande's song.
- Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
- And it was incredible.
- [Kelly] I love that song.
- Loved it.
- Yes.